In a couple of the problems before, we distributed the parenthesis on the
outside to the exponents on the inside of the parenthesis. We can also do this
with fractions. If we think all the way back to unit 1, we saw 1 3rd times 1 3rd
times 1 3rd. We knew that result was 1 27th. We found this answer by multiplying
1 3rd by itself three times. There was actually another way we could have
thought about this. I know the exponent on this base, 1, is a 1. And the
exponent on this base of 3 is also a 1. We can distribute this exponent of 3, or
multiply it to each of the exponents on the inside of the parentheses. So we've
a base of 1 and an exponent of 1 times 3, and a base of 3 with an exponent of 1
times 3. This is really 1 cubed, and this is really 3 cubed, or 1 divided by 27.
If we can get to this step more quickly, then we can get to our answer, 1 cubed
is 1, and 3 cubed is 27. Here we have a negative sign, and we're going to square
it, so we know our answer should be positive. So I'm going to have negative 5
squared and x squared. So all together, we have 25 divided by x squared. This
last case of variables works just like this first example. We'll have a to the
5th, divided by b to the 5th. We just multiply the exponents on the inside of
the parenthesis by the exponent on the outside. We raised a power to a power.